antenne de 20h le journal de la
rédaction
henri sannier bonsoir j'espère que vous
avez passé un excellent week end à la
une ce soir françois mitterrand sur rtl
interview et petites phrases affaires
lüscher j'ai donné la directive de ne
rien vendre à l'iran
l'exploitation du rapport barba une
immense escroquerie morale financement
des partis politiques
il faut en finir avec cette boue dans
quelques instants commentaires et
analyse avec paul amar
première distribution de prix
littéraires le goncourt à l'écrivain
marocain tahar bendjelloun pour la nuit
sacrée leur loto à rené jean claud pour
l'enfant à lui signer un nouveau trafic
d'armes entre la france et l'iran
révélée par le quotidien le matin des
milliers de tonnes d'explosifs auraient
été illégalement livrer à téhéran entre
82 et 85 lancement de l'emprunt
eurotunnel 7,7 milliards de francs pour
construire le tunnel sous la manche les
pentes compléteront l'apport des petits
épargnants français et britanniques
catastrophe aérienne aux états unis un
dc9 s'écrase au décollage sur l'aéroport
de denver en pleine tempête de neige
milan 26 morts 56 blessés
une journée supplémentaire de détention
pour marcel carton
marcel fontaine jean paul kauffmann jean
louis normandin d'antenne 2 et roger
auque les otages français au liban n'ont
toujours pas été libérés
françois mitterrand s'explique c'était
il ya un peu plus d'une heure sur
l'antenne de nos confrères de rtl en
tête de l'entretien la sphère du cher le
président est formelle dès 1980 at il
dit j'ai confirmé les directives de ne
rien vendre à l'iran
écoutons le la constitution ne m'a pas
confier la charge de vérifier les
autorisations d'exportation de matériel
de guerre et est que si l'on m'en
informe qu'un entendu en tient compte
j'informe les autorités responsables
je n'en ai quêtes diverses reprises je
les fais à diverses reprises dans le
courant de l'année 1984 et dès lors que
les systèmes de contrôles fonctionnent
en d'humains forme de rien moi je suis
quand même tout à fait autorisé à penser
qu'il n'y a plus d' infraction à la
règle que j'ai moi même édictées
lorsque je rencontre une l'amiral la
coche lorsque je le reçois le 21 mai
1984 je lui dis aussi tous les lieux lui
même le d'éclat parlez-en active à votre
ministre à votre supérieur hiérarchique
ce qu'il fait est je crois le 24 mai et
moi aussi je lui dis je lui en parlerai
ce que je fais dans le même délai vous
mettriez votre nom au feu que le parti
socialiste à quelques niveaux ce soir et
vous national au niveau local n'a pas
retiré à sous de ce qu'il faut bien
appeler un trafic
oui je mettrais ma main au feu et
personnellement je pense que la manière
dont le rapport barbe a été divulguée ce
qui est aussi une affaire d'état
alors qu'une instruction judiciaire
avait déjà été ouverte et qu'il
appartenait aux juges d'instruction des
graminées selon les méthodes de la
justice
la situation des personnes mises en
cause de sa manière dans le rapport
barba étaient divulgués et la façon dont
il a été exploité notamment contre le
parti socialiste en annonçant qu'il
avait reçu des soultes des commissions
de l'argent sur les ventes d'armes à
l'iran
je considère que cela constitue une
immense escroquerie morale à l'égard de
ce parti autre temps fort de cette
interview radiodiffusée le financement
des partis politiques le président
souhaite la clarté sur le financement
est là ils formulent une proposition il
faut se décider
il faut en finir avec c'est avec quand
il fait beau
puis alors ceux qui passeront quand même
à travers pour commettre les actions de
frau de malhonnête alors seront dix fois
plus coupables devront être sanctionné
plus encore plus fermement
alors le moyen le référendum a dit je
crois
l'un des leaders de la majorité actuelle
moi je pense que c'est encore plus
simple plus possible il suffit que le
gouvernement dépose une loi devant
l'assemblée nationale dans les gens y
viennent en tout cas avant la fin de la
session et que cette loi suivent
normalement la procédure parlementaire
et si on n'y arrive pas avant le 25 et
le 30 décembre parce qu'il ya aussi le
vote du budget des gens compétents
programmée de la changer
eh bien je suis prêt à signer un décret
de convocation du parlement en session
extraordinaire au mois de janvier
de telle sorte que l'assemblée nationale
et le sénat pourrait disposer
tes jours nécessaires au moins une
semaine pour en finir une fois pour
toutes avec cette question qui
empoisonne la vie des républiques depuis
plus de 100 ans l'économie le président
françois mitterrand trouve normal que le
gouvernement marque une pause dans sa
politique de privatisation il lance
également un appel à la cohésion il
formulera quelques propositions
d'ailleurs lors du prochain sommet de
copenhague sommet des chefs d'état en
matière de justice
autre petite phrase très percutante du
chef de l'état laissons les juges
travaillent et personnellement je ne
suis jamais intervenu et je reste le
garant de l'autorité judiciaire
je suis par l'article 64 de la
constitution - président de la
république garant de l'indépendance de
l'autorité judiciaire
je peux et je devrai s'il le faut
consulter le conseil supérieur de la
magistrature pour qu'il me donne son
avis sur telle ou telle action qui
viserait à enrayer la liberté ou la
dépendance des juges notamment des juges
d'instruction voilà une déclaration de
principe qui peut devenir une
déclaration pratique jeu mais je ne peux
pas faire que les politiques dans leur
ensemble respecte les principes que je
viens d'énoncer je peux contribuer à ce
que la justice se sont enfin délivré de
c'est inadmissible pression et je le
ferai
voilà marc bonsoir vous avez été
attentifs aux propos du président de la
république est ce que françois
mitterrand a réussi à éclaircir le
paysage politique
drôlement assombrie par les affaires ces
derniers temps réussi il est sans doute
trop tôt pour le dire mais on a le
sentiment après l'avoir donc écouter sur
rtl que le président de la république a
adopté la même défense la même attitude
que lors de la faire une grille
greenpeace autrement dit profil bas
profil très bas
il s'est contenté de dire qu'il n'a été
alertés qu'une seule fois par l'amiral
lacoste le patron des services spéciaux
le 21 mai 1984 après plus rien silence
radio et à toutes les questions posées
par notre confrère philippe alexandre
qui revenait avec ténacité sur la sphère
lüscher le chef de l'état a répondu
toujours de la même façon
moi disait-il en substance je ne savais
pas la seule fois où j'ai su la seule
fois où marat
orthez la rumeur et bien j'en ai
aussitôt parler à charles hernu tout de
même at il ajouté je ne suis pas chargé
de vérifier les exportations de matériel
de guerre
françois mitterrand n'est donc pas
descendue de l'aventin où il se trouve
depuis le 16 mars 86 pour polémiquer
directement avec la majorité avec une
partie de la majorité
sans doute parce qu'ils estiment qu elle
lui tend un piège dans lequel il ne veut
pas tomber
l'obus si j'ose dire est passé très près
et c'est la raison pour laquelle ne pas
rentrer dans la bagarre il se raidit
prendrait le risque d'être atteint
d'être touchés plus sérieusement mais
comme n'a pas voulu donner l'impression
de rester sur la défensive il a aussitôt
fait une proposition
nous l'avons entendu sur le financement
des partis politiques
il prend ainsi la majorité au pied de la
drees et bien si vous voulez parler
d'argent at il dit en substance
allons-y des ballons tout cela m'a fait
penser ce qu'il avait fait sur l'école
privée en 84 au moins il avait retiré le
projet sur l'école privée où il avait
proposé le référendum c'est la technique
du contre-pied quand il est en
difficulté il attaque ou plutôt contre
attaque n'a pas l'impression qu'ils
calment un peu le jeu quand même ce soir
françois mitterrand oui impression
confirmée par plusieurs indices ou
plusieurs déclarations je les reprends
pas d'élections présidentielles
anticipées malgré le climat
pas de dissolution de l'assemblée
nationale et pas d' attaque vous l'avez
dit contre la politique économique du
gouvernement c'est même assez surprenant
il n'a pas profité en quelque sorte de
la crise boursière pour dénoncer les
privatisations
alors pourquoi cette dédramatisation
pour une raison essentielle qui
s'appelle la cohabitation françois
mitterrand sait très bien qu'une
aggravation du climat politique
rejaillirait sur rue ce qu'il appelle la
coexistence est à dire sur les deux
principaux acteurs lui et jacques chirac
au profit peut-être d'un troisième homme
qui s'appelle raymond barre
peu de réaction tout au moins dans
l'immédiat je vous donne deux ou trois
réactions qui viennent de me parvenir
1h28 d'interviewer rien sur ce qui
préoccupe les gens je n'ai pas entendu
parler de sécurité sociale ni de pouvoir
d'achat ni de chômage c'est jean claude
gayssot qui s'exprime ainsi au nom du
parti communiste français marcel debarge
pour le ps souligne que monsieur
mitterrand a interdit lui même les
ventes d'armes à l'iran et qu il a parlé
simplement de cette affaire et que c'est
de toute façon à la justice de se
prononcer pour jean marie le pen le
président de la république et steve ses
responsabilités en faisant porter le
chapeau
charles hernu son ancien ministre de la
défense pour le président du front
national françois mitterrand est un peu
facteurs qu'on informe qui transmet qui
retransmet sans prendre de décision
fin de citation déclarations de jean
marie le pen il y à quelques minutes sur
les antennes de france inter à peine
oubliée la sphère lüscher que l'on
embraie sur une affaire du service nos
confrères du matin qui soit dit en
passant
changes le look de la une de leur
journal publie aujourd'hui une série de
documents qui tendent à prouver qu'une
société d'état
la snp eux auraient vendu des explosifs
à l'iran de 82 à 85 dans cette affaire
l'intermédiaire serait à suédois c'est
chez lui que les douanes ont saisi des
documents compromettants
aujourd'hui la snp aux dément
formellement on fait le point avec
thierry calmette la société nationale
des poudres et explosifs société
contrôlée par l'état at elle vendu à
l'iran 84 et 85 800 tonnes de poudre et
250 tonnes d'explosifs pour au but une
révélation du journal le matin
d'après le quotidien le trafic n'aurait
pu s'effectuer sans la complicité des
plus hautes autorités
la poudre les explosifs fabriqués dans
les usines de la snpe à bergerac et à
sorgues était officiellement acheminés
vers la suède
les sociétés scandinaves yonne et scanex
dirigé par carl smith serre auraient
servi d'écran pour les transactions avec
l'iran depuis ses bureaux de malmö carr
smith aurait conclu le marché pour le
compte de la snp ce sont les documents
publiés par le matin à la direction de
la snp eux on dément la société a bien
livré 800 tonnes de poudre et 250 tonnes
d'explosifs à la société suédoise
mais le véritable client pour la
marchandise devait être l'argentine ce
qui explique que le marché était
régulièrement couverts par les
autorisations administratives des
ministères de la défense
alors que l'acheteur argentine ou iran
quel est le rôle exact de carl smith
d'après certains télex la livraison du
21 janvier 85 ne devait être que la
première d'une série la bonne foi de
l'asm pe a pu être abusés
à moins que la société soit au centre
d'une nouvelle affaire d'exportation
d'armes vers l'iran la semaine qui
commence pourrait bien marquer le début
d'une certaine remise en ordre sur les
marchés financiers et monétaires les
chiffres d'aujourd'hui confirme les
velléités de reprise +4 9% aujourd'hui à
la bourse de paris
hausse du dollar et fermeté du franc
apparemment il a suffi que ronald reagan
en personne annonce un accord imminent
avec le congrès autour de la réduction
du déficit américain pour que le calme
s'installe à nouveau aujourd'hui à
bruxelles à la situation économique et
monétaire était au coeur du débat les
les grands argentiers de la cee ont
essayé de renforcer leur cohésion face
aux problèmes économiques et ils ont
demandé aux etats unis une nouvelle fois
de réduire en priorité leurs déficits
budgétaires
sur place on a également fait remarquer
avec insistance que le s émeut le
système monétaire européen avait plutôt
bien résisté dans une période très
difficile
en dépit des incertitudes boursière les
dirigeants d'eurotunnel ont décidé de
mettre en vente leurs actions
aujourd'hui au prix record de 35 francs
j'ai bien dit 35 francs l'unité
objectif de cette société franco
britannique levé 7,7 milliards de francs
pour s'assurer le concours des banques à
londres plus de 600 milles souscripteurs
se sont déjà manifestés philippe
harrouard les anglais n'hésitent plus à
sauter à pieds joints dans l'europe
la tour eiffel et bigben réunis oui ont
déjà répondu 500000 futurs petits
actionnaires de l'eurotunnel 500 milles
qui se sont engagés à acquérir des
actions
c'est plutôt une surprise les grandes
banques ont finalement apporté leur
garantie c'est à dire qu elles
achèteront toutes les actions délaissé
par le public après le récent krach
financier ce n'était pas évident je vais
donc aujourd'hui pour l'avant 350 pence
35 cents l'unité pour aller chez la
clientèle qui doit maintenant passer à
la caisse la publicité précise que les
détenteurs d'au moins 100 actions
bénéficieront de plusieurs voyages
gratuits etc avec 1500 action la
traversée se fera sans stress et sans
limite
jusqu'en
1040 de robert maxwell le magnat de la
presse devraient en profiter puisque en
européen convaincu il a dit ont
l'intention d'acquérir plus de 10 % de
la part britannique
après un an de préparatifs les grandes
manoeuvres de l'europe ils elles vont
commencer le mois prochain
on pense vraiment qu enfin on verra le
bout du tunnel
et oui c'est parti pour tout savoir sur
eurotunnel et surtout sur les ventes des
actions je vous conseille de jeter un
coup d'oeil sur votre mini telle antenne
de vous en donne plus il suffit de faire
le 36 15 et de taper aequo à 2 jean le
beurre dites moi tout oui et bien en
regardant justement le minitel vous
auriez eu tous les détails sur la
souscription à partir d'aujourd'hui de
route des actions d'eurotunnel
mais pour en savoir plus nous allons
vous présenter l'intérieur du système
c'est à dire que par rapport à un menu
qui s'affiche maintenant sur notre écran
vous avez un certain nombre de rubriques
qui vous tiennent informés sur les
cotations sur le second marché les clubs
d'investissement une revue de presse et
surtout depuis aujourd'hui aequo à deux
vous reconnaissez la porte à porte qui
est un et trois millions 800 mille
actionnaires à paribas le club des
actionnaires de paribas dans cette
rubrique les actionnaires trouveront une
nouvelle communication un nouveau
langage
ils pourront dialoguer avec l'état-major
de paribas en pleine crise il ya eu un
boum sur les consultations jean-louis
d'un mois sur l'autre on est passé de
135 mille consultant à 275 mille
personnes et le 19 et le 20 à 6 heures
du matin il y avait mille branché sur
aequo à 2 6 heures du matin 6 heures du
matin il vient là même à minuit à 2h du
matin il y en a qui dormait pas là un
nom je croisais faisait beaucoup de 6,6
est ce que les téléspectateurs vont
pouvoir vous poser des questions
oui d'une part à nous mais surtout à
l'état major de paribas ils vont pouvoir
s'interroger sur le recul de l'action
paribas et ils vont obtenir des réponses
pourront dialoguer avec l'êta majeur du
paribas ils pourront aussi commander de
la documentation les rapports annuels
rapport semestriel
il ya l'avenir vous allez pouvoir faire
des consultations plus personnalisé
disons si cela du sur mesure en vain les
plus loin on va faire du calcul de la
retraite et de l'évaluation de
patrimoine merci qu'elles auront
rappelle 36 15 codes et cohade et cohade
merci en pologne
à quinze jours du référendum proposé par
le général jariza de ski un référendum
sur les réformes politiques et
économiques
plusieurs opposants polonais ont annoncé
hier à varsovie
la création d'un nouveau parti politique
le parti socialiste polonais les
militants de ce parti dont la première
réunion a été interrompue par la police
reprennent un certain nombre
d'initiatives qui était celle de
solidarnosc et ce n'est peut-être pas un
hasard d'ailleurs si lech walesa
rappelle par ailleurs qu'il est hostile
au principe du référendum
reportage de pascal perri et thomas la
baisse avec le référendum du 29 novembre
le gouvernement polonais cherche
semble-t-il a regagné de sa légitimité
les deux questions qui seront posées
tournent autour de la politique
économique et des libertés
en substance il s'agit de savoir si les
polonais sont prêts à se serrer la
ceinture deux ou trois ans et s'il
approuve le modèle de société dans
lequel ils vivent
pour l'ex walesa ces deux questions
n'ont pas de sens solidarnost boycottera
le référendum
nous disons non au référendum
la société polonaise n'en a pas besoin
c'est le pouvoir qui a besoin d'une
leçon de démocratie d'hakim
voilà pourquoi nous considérons que
participer au référendum c'est un non
sens nous avons déjà demandé un
référendum en 80 dont 81
nous n'avons pas changé d'avis à ce
sujet cela dit un référendum doit
répondre à de véritables questions dans
la mesure où les citoyens ne peuvent ni
participer à la formulation des
questions ni vérifier la sincérité du
résultat ni bénéficier de la morale du
référendum
il est difficile d'imaginer qu'ils y
participent pour sa part le gouvernement
polonais accuse solidarnosc que de
vouloir retarder l'application de
réformes dans le pays
cela dit la manoeuvre engagée par
l'équipe jaruzelski ne recueille que peu
d'écho les polonais ne crois pas dans
leur gouvernement vous rencontrez des
plus en plus 20 les gens qui vous disent
si vous la poser la question mais qu'est
ce que vous passez de penser de ce
gouvernement là vous savez que ce qu'on
perd enfance et ses chiens évidemment ce
gouvernement là est ce que ça vaut la
peine de les répéter
la partie de bras de fer est désormais
engagé entre gouvernement et opposition
la télévision polonaise a même ouvert
une ligne téléphonique spéciale
référendum
de son côté la presse clandestine de
solidarnosc explique dans tous ces
bulletins qu'il convient d'éviter le
piège du 29
le message est clair pas de chèque en
blanc au gouvernement cette fois ci on a
l'impression que les systèmes venise
dans l'europe de l'est est en crise tous
les systèmes et que pour la première
fois les forces dirigeantes des systèmes
on a conscience que ça ne tourne plus et
qu'il faut faire quelque chose
le 29 novembre environ 15 millions de
polonais sont appelés à se prononcer sur
leur avenir
cependant au delà du référendum beaucoup
estiment déjà que le régime a plus à
perdre qu'à gagner
depuis le 12 septembre dernier on
s'interroge sur le sort de notre
confrère alain guillot alain guillot est
un reporter indépendant qui travaille
épisodiquement pour l' agence sygma
il est actuellement détenu à kaboul en
afghanistan et il fait l'objet d'une
enquête pour la première fois nous
sommes en mesure ce soir de vous montrer
des images qui témoignent de la présence
d'allain guilloux dans ce pays le
document que vous allez voir a été
tournée par un afghan qui a pu échapper
à l'embuscade jérôme baugnies juillet 87
un groupe de moudjahidine s'apprête à
rentrer en afghanistan parmi eux un
homme apparemment détendu à billets
comme eux mais lui n'y va pas pour se
battre
il est français reporter c'est alain
guyot
son reportage aurait sans doute commencé
comme celui ci avec la longue traversée
du pays en guerre des moudjahidine à
bout de force se battant pour la moindre
goutte d'eau un homme épuisé
s'effondrant au bord de la route
interminable qui mène à daoulas abad
près de la frontière soviétique
un millier de kilomètres dans cette
région ouzbèke où les journalistes sont
rares guyot a formé de jeunes afghans au
maniement de la caméra
c'est l'un d'entre eux qui a tourné ces
images dans un bazar où lui ue va filmer
sans le savoir ce qu'ils vont devenir
les acteurs de sa propre histoire à la
tête de ce qu'on voit au volant de la
voiture de commandement un homme qui a
secrètement trail et va le donner aux
soviétiques
pourtant on l'a mise en garde contre ce
rassoul palawan meurtrier de plusieurs
résistants dont son propre commandant
dans la même voiture
à gauche le commandant amin qui a pris
lui ou en charge
rassoul et son fils adoptif et il va
accepter après beaucoup d'hésitations un
rendez vous pour une opération militaire
encore inconscients du danger
guyot remercié en anglais le commandant
convient de lui présenter le lendemain
il va tomber dans une embuscade tendue
par les hommes de rassoul plusieurs
moudjahidine seront tués amine et guyot
capturé puis livrée aux soviétiques
un comité a été constitué pour la
libération du journaliste
les amis d'alain guyot boîtes postales
99-92 134 issy-les-moulineaux cedex
et à propos de la situation en
afghanistan dont parlait jérôme baugnies
monsieur guerre asimov porte parole du
ministère des affaires étrangères
soviétique a déclaré aujourd'hui à
munich que les troupes soviétiques était
prêt à se retirer dans un délai de sept
à douze mois mais autre télégramme de
l'actualité avec isabelle tu es sans
suite nous reviendrons sur l'attribution
des prix littéraires c'était aujourd'hui
à paris
nouvelles attaques dans le golfe un
superpétrolier de la compagnie
américaine exxon est un bâtiment grecs
ont été touchés aujourd'hui près du
détroit d'ormuz lire en riposte aux
raids aériens de l'irak en une semaine
bagdad aux attaques et 11 navires
iraniens
federico mayor officiellement installé à
la direction générale de l'unesco
c'était ce matin à paris deux semaines
après son élection mouvementée mayor en
place de sénégalais and go durée de son
mandat 6 ans une ambition faire revenir
l'angleterre et les états unis ainsi
qu'aux bailleurs de fonds de l'unesco la
reine margarethe de haute de françois
mitterrand la souveraine danoise
inaugure à paris l'année des échanges
culturels france danemark l'orfèvrerie
du xviiie au programme d'aujourd'hui la
reine inaugurera au total trois
expositions
collision ferroviaire près du port
suédois de göteborg au moins cinq morts
et 50 blessés et deux trains circulaient
sur la même voie et systèmes de sécurité
automatique aurait été débranché en
raison de travaux
mélodie vivante une preuve cette photo
envoyée aujourd'hui par les ravisseurs
de la petite fille enlevée lundi près de
marcela en espagne ultimatum fixé par
ses parents la chanteuse kymera et le
milliardaire n'a quatre chiens expire
demain la libération de mélodies contre
une rançon
enfin de 75 millions francs l étranger
toujours les suites immédiates du sommet
dahmane dont on a beaucoup parlé on
apprend que l'arabie saoudite a décidé
de rétablir ses relations diplomatiques
avec l'egypte les relations étaient
rompues depuis 1979 à la suite de la
signature d'un traité de paix entre
l'egypte et israël
à paris pas de surprise dans
l'attribution des prix littéraires le
goncourt que voici a été décerné à tahar
benjelloun pour son roman la nuit sacrée
le renaudot à rené jean claud pour
l'enfant à l'us idée que voilà tard
bendjelloul pense que son prix goncourt
a une portée politique et que son
attribution rejaillit sur toute la
communauté maghrébine
sylvie marion il aura fallu la
publication de 15 romans à rené jean
claud pour être couronné par un grand
prix littéraire avec son enfant
halluciné aux éditions grasset il aura
fallu toute l'histoire de la littérature
française pour qu un maghrébin un
marocain tahar ben jelloun reçoivent le
plus recherché les prix le goncourt avec
la nuit sacrée paru aux éditions du
seuil je pense que ce prix a une portée
symbolique politique s'appelle mans et
bon il eu la meilleure chose à faire
c'est de continuer à écrire je pense
marc et prépare car votre mère est
analphabète elle ne peut donc pas lire
vos livres mais est-ce qu'elle va
comprendre ce que c'est qu'un prix
goncourt
celui-ci elle ne dit pas mais je lui
raconte mes livres je les appelais tout
à l'heure malheureusement les lignes les
lignes étaient préoccupés mais elle a
prié pour moi le piller ce matin et
l'afrique est fière et je crois beaucoup
en ses prières c'est un bon j'ai un
rapport très fort avec elle je pense que
l'amour qu'elle a pour moi et que j'ai
pour être ça s'est couronné comme ça par
ce succès il y a quelques jours tahar
benjelloun nous parler de son travail
d'écrivain mais j'ai l'impression que
lorsque j'écris en français que je donne
hospitalité fin pas moi en tant
qu'individu mais dans ma culture dans
l'hostilité à sa trogne ce qui fait que
beaucoup de la culture marocaine orale
arabe berbère se trouve
de verser dans la langue française
l'important c'est d'être sincère dans
ses propres racines de ne pas jouer au
parisien quand on est au maroc et puis
s'il joue elle a déjà son roman
précédent l'enfant de sable a été un
best-seller avec la nuit sacrée la suite
de ce très beau conte oriental tahar
bendjelloun doit devenir un excellent
prix goncourt et ce soir à 23h10 sur
antenne de tahar ben jelloun sera
l'invité de bernard pivot dans strophe
je vous rappelle l'horaire 23h10 sur
antenne 2
aux etats unis la tragique loi des
séries 24 heures après la catastrophe du
dc9 de la continental airlines on a
appris tout à l'heure qu'un bimoteur
d'une compagnie régionale américaine
s'était écrasé près de madison dans le
wisconsin
bilan huit morts pendant ce temps là
d'un verre dans le colorado l'enquète
s'annonce difficile au lendemain de la
catastrophe qui a fait 26 morts et 56
blessés avant le décryptage de la
fameuse boîte noire ce sont surtout les
déclarations des survivants qui alimente
la réflexion
on fait également remarquer que
l'aéroport avait été fermé quelques
heures seulement avant l'accident à
cause de mauvaises conditions météo
dominique verdeilhan déficience humaine
défection du système de dégivrage erreur
de pilotage d'une visibilité ne
dépassant pas 2 100 m on ignore encore
ce soir les causes de la catastrophe
d'hier à demain
il semble néanmoins que les mauvaises
conditions métérologiques au colorado ne
soit pas étrangère à cet accident
une violente tempête de neige avait
durant quelques heures interrompu le
trafic aérien
le dc-9 devait-il ou non décoller aux
états unis comme au japon ce sont les
bureaux les compagnies aériennes qui
décide ou non de faire décoller leurs
appareils
aux etats unis le choix de piste le
choix des éléments de décollage et
préparer au sol par ce que l'on appelle
à dispatcheur c'est à dire qu'entre les
services au sol de la compagnie et la
commandant de bord se trouve un monsieur
qui a un rôle décisionnel qui s'appelle
le dispatcheur en france ceci n'existe
absolument pas le monsieur qui prend la
décision est la boîte noire en dira plus
dans quelques semaines sur les
responsabilités de cette catastrophe qui
a fait 26 morts et plus de 50 blessés le
souci économique et de rentabilité de
certaines compagnies aériennes et
quelquefois en totale contradiction avec
la volonté des pilotes de ligne qui
tiennent à ce que la sécurité prime sur
la ponctualité la météo laurent cabrol
apparemment le soleil revient sur
l'hexagone mais il faut faire le ménage
comme moniteur oui c'est à dire notre
météo prend des allures un peu de tâches
ménagères ne l'ont donné un coup de
serpillière pourquoi bien parce que nous
avions énormément d'humilité accumulés
dans le sol avec la pluie d'hier les
ondes et de ce matin et cette humilité
va falloir qu'elle s'en aille pour
qu'elle s'en aille
nous aurons des brumes débrouillarde et
demain et nous allons quand même avoir
le retour du soleil grâce à un
anticyclone puisque vous le voyez
d'abord ces nuages qui était sur la
france aujourd'hui s'en sont allés mais
vous riez ici ce jeu trace là peu près
là le ventre de l'anticyclone un
anticyclone qui est allongé sur les
l'espagne et qui va gonfler sur la
france ce qui va nous donner donc ce
temps dans les deux ou trois jours qui
viennent à temps plus frais mais aussi
plus ensoleillé pour la journée de
demain déjà
voyons ce qui va se passer avec ici donc
quelques nuages grisonnants sur l'est
sur le nord est aussi mais aussi sur les
pyrénées-orientales
partout ailleurs un temps assez agréable
dans l'ensemble avec même sur le
pourtour méditerranéen des belles
périodes ensoleillées
les températures pour demain font des
températures qui sont encore
relativement sympa pour la saison 9
degrés à strasbourg et puis nous avons
un petit groupe de 11 degrés ici à
clermont ferrand et lyon et grenoble et
il fera il fera tenez 11 degrés ou ici à
goncourt ça existe goncourt c'est en
haute marne
célèbre pour son prix en fait henri de
boncourt n'est pas né à goncourt mais il
est né à nancy lille parce que celui qui
avait créé le prix voilà et demain nous
fêterons les elisabeth bonne fête les
elizabeth alors que si elle va se le
soleil le ciel lui restera toujours le
soleil va se lever à 8h03 se coucher à
10 heures 17h07
prochain rendez vous d'information 23h30
avec au bruit et de l'air demain 6h45
ouvrez l'oeil comme tous les matins avec
télématin et son trio roger zabel
catherine ceylac et marc hautement le
signale qu à 7h45 les 4 vérités ont
comme invité jean claude gaudin qui
n'est autre que le président du groupe
udf à l'assemblée nationale
voilà excellente soirée sur antenne 2
bonté les matins pour ceux qui se lèvent
tôt et je retrouve demain à 20h bonsoir